cuántas horas son quinientos cuarenta y
nueve minutos y lo puedes resolver como
un decimal o una fracción así que
esencialmente vamos a tomar 549 minutos
y los dividiremos en grupos de 60 y
porque es 60 porque nosotros sabemos que
una hora es igual a 60 minutos
entonces esencialmente tenemos que decir
en cuántos grupos de 60 minutos podemos
dividir nuestros 500 49 minutos y otra
forma en cómo pensarlo es cuántos son
549 dividido entre grupos de 60 y esto
es cuántas horas vamos a tener y hagamos
lo siguiente todos los 549 y los
dividimos entre 60 entre 60 así que al
dividir 549 entre 60 por algo que se
acerque a 549 al multiplicarlo por 60
podría ser 9 pues 9 por 6
son 540 al restarse lo a 549 nos restan
9 y ponemos nuestro punto decimal sin
antes olvidar poner nuestros dos ceros
por aquí bajamos nuestro primer 0 60 por
1 son 60 y al restarse loa 90 nos restan
30 bajamos nuestro segundo 0 y 60 por 5
son 300 este número 5 nos da la cantidad
exacta entonces 300 menos 300 0 y listo
aquí lo tenemos 549 entre 60 es igual a
9.15 9.15 grupos de 60 minutos y un
grupo de 60 minutos es igual a una hora
entonces estos 500 49 minutos son 9.15
horas y quiero estar segura de que está
visualizando esto como debe de ser por
lo que vamos a construir cómo lucen
estas 9.15 horas
así que déjame dibujar una línea por
aquí y en la parte superior de nuestra
línea voy a escribir las horas y en la
parte de abajo en la parte inferior voy
a escribir los minutos por lo que estas
serán horas y estos cero minutos luego
entonces tenemos una hora que son 60
minutos 2 horas 120 minutos así hasta
cinco horas son trescientos minutos seis
horas trescientos sesenta minutos siete
horas cuatrocientos veinte minutos pero
un momento aquí esto se me va a encimar
con mis cálculos anteriores y no quiero
que suceda entonces déjame copio y lo
pegamos por aquí y continuamos con
nuestra línea entonces ocho horas son
igual a 480 minutos y llegamos a las 9
horas se supone que entre cada intervalo
hay 60 minutos entonces aquí son 540
minutos pero nosotros no tenemos
solamente 540 minutos tenemos
un poco más a la derecha por lo que
luego vamos a tener vamos a tener
nuestros otros nueve minutos que son
estos quinientos cuarenta y nueve en
total nueve minutos a la derecha y otra
forma de pensar esto es que esos
quinientos cuarenta y nueve minutos son
nueve horas y luego tenemos nueve
minutos sobrantes y esos nueve minutos
sobrantes que fracción de hora son bien
pues esos sesenta minutos son una hora
por lo que en nueve minutos serían nueve
sobre sesenta de una hora por lo que
entonces tenemos nueve horas por nueve
centavos de hora o bien puedes
escribirlo de otra forma como una
fracción pero bueno a dividir nueve
sobre 60 ambos son divisibles entre 3
por lo que esto sería igual a tener 9
horas por 3 veinteavos de hora pero si
hacemos esta división 3 sobre 60 podemos
imaginar lo de la silla
forma esto obviamente va a ser menor que
1 pues 3 es muy menor que 20 por lo que
entonces ponemos nuestro punto decimal
hacemos nuestras debidas operaciones y
finalmente llegamos a que nuestro
resultado es igual a punto 15 entonces
esto también podríamos escribirlo como
9.15 que son los 3 veinteavos de hora y
estas son las posibles respuestas